où vous vous trouvez vous pensez que
willy bernard laporte ça dépend du
caractère de chacun mais moi je suis je
les dis d'ailleurs j'ai envoyé un petit
message dit bravo c'est très très fort
de sa part et je crois d'un court c'est
difficile de parler pour les gens moi je
sais pas si j si je serai capable de le
dire si ça m'arrivait mais je trouve ça
très très courageux de l'extérieur ça
donne énormément de forces et nos mains
de courage et voilà c'est pour ça que
j'étais témoigner de mon message depuis
dublin c'est d'abord j'étais bien sûr
touchés comme tout le monde c'est parti
comme disait série delà de la famille
terrain coup et quand quelqu'un est
touché mais on est touché c'est une
évidence
mediapart il m'a donné la force
évidemment aussi et je regardais tout à
l'heure bernard tapie je les écoutais
une fois de 18 dans une des rues
démission il n'a fait chialer
comment tu peux être aussi fort quand tu
dis mais peut-être je passerai pas
l'année que j'étais assez extraordinaire
le met dans la tête
non voilà donc ce c'est ça dépend de
tellement de chacun c'est difficile de
dire je réagirais comme ça ou pas je
trouve que c'est très fort et nous
envoyer un message pour une fois très
costaud bravo à toi gâtés puis costaud
comme du et arrivera rien vous parlez de
bernard tapie
il ya un instant justement là il ya
quelques jours il ya un journaliste qui
a posé une question au sujet de son
cancer et cette dernière a beaucoup
choqué regarde alors je vais poser une
question atroce ouais si demain vous
disparaissez qu'est ce qu'il advient de
tous les procès merci savas avertissent
à écouter si vous voulez bien mais c'est
pour aux enfants et ne sais pas encore
la procédure s'arrêtera pas de pure n ya
pas de retenue j'avais pas monétique
avec 2 a vous
entendez apprend bon en tout cas alors
que c'est excellent pour ce journaliste
normand c'est jérôme bégué voilà il m'a
posé la question et c'est vrai que çà çà
çà çà choqué bernard tapie ou on aime
pas seulement bernard tapie il ya des
lignes rouges anti wade est tombé sur un
gène dit bernard et fils et moi je les
crânes peut-être à dessein
bah voila mais c'est lundi dans ce qui
fait du bon boulot normalement jérôme
béglé voilà ça n'empêche pas que là il a
passé les limites
voilà je tous les coups ne sont pas
permis sur un plateau de télévision
on peut tout dire avec dignité mais là
c'est pas digne il ya des limites à ne
pas verser dans l'indécence
karim la question voilà les stars qui
parlent publiquement de leur maladie est
ce que vous trouvez qu'elles ont raison
moi j'ai toujours dit que c'était une
affaire très intime et très personnelle
est que chacun devait faire le choix de
mettre sur la place publique sa maladie
en conscience certains ont envie de se
battre plutôt dans un cadre intime c'est
leur choix il faut le respecter et
d'autres moment donné on envie aussi de
le partager parce que c'est difficile de
le cacher et moi je pense que agathe
elle va nous le dire mais elle était un
peu dans cette situation je savais
depuis un moment qu'elle était frappée
par cette maladie elle avait voulu un
temps donné le garder dans un cadre plus
intime et lala eu envie de le partager à
ceux qu'il aimait à ceux qui la suivait
avec beaucoup de transparence de dignité
de force et elle l'a fait parce que
peut-être que elle s'est dit que j'en
avais besoin elle est que vis-à-vis de
la relation qu'a la baie avec les gens
on n'avait pas envie de leur donner ce
sentiment qu'elle mente et qu'elle ne
disait pas quelque chose et en même
temps je suis sûr qu'elle va donner de
la force à des gens qui sont dans la
même situation qu'elle
elle vendait dans la force parce que moi
qui connais agathe et beaucoup
d'affection poil de que je sais que
c'est une battante qui a des valeurs
elle est debout donc elle va pas
abdiquer elle baissera pas la tête à la
beaucoup d'énergie elle fait du sport
deux fois par semaine alors qu'elle ne
faisait pas attendre et non mais c'est
vrai ces gars tu vas chercher des
ressources extraordinaires et le fait
que tu te battre comme ça et que tu
lèves la tête que tu souris tu sois
aussi belle aussi rayonnante
agathe itunes
sont de vie que tu donnes là vous
regardez jimmy mohamed investirait
qu'agathe elle est un gars tels et elle
a toujours le sourire
c'est vrai qu' et pour ceux qui ne
savaient pas je pense qu'il s'en douter
pas du tout alors eric revel vous sur le
crâne en voilage et bages comme tout le
monde j'ai envoyé un sms à la garde
parce que j'ai été frappé moi je vais
vous dire un truc je n'aurais pas eu le
courage de ska gars tu as fait je
n'aurais pas eu le courage parce que
même si j'ai l'air grand costaud etc je
pense qu'elle est plus forte
elle est plus forte que moi parce que
dans la même situation je crois que
j'aurais pas pu me l'avouer à moi-même
et j'aurais pas pu le dire aux autres
parce que j'aurais été mais je suis
passé par cette phase de déni complet et
j'ajoute autre chose agathe très
important pour moi c'est que les gens
qui ont de la notoriété une célébrité
c'est super important pour moi c'est
pour ça que j'ai mis un oui j'aurais pu
mettre un oui grand comme ça qu'ils le
disent aux autres parce que en fait les
gens qui partagent un quotidien - moins
lumineux moins fort je pense que ça les
aide à se dire finalement des gens qui
sourient qui sont la télévision ils
partagent la même souffrance et les
mêmes problèmes que nous donc moi cent
fois oui et puis je vais te dire un truc
juste pour reprendre le mot de karim ton
enthousiasme ton énergie est ta beauté
la laideur de la maladie peut pas
triomphé
eric naulleau d'abord j'ai été comme
tout le monde très ému je connais pas
agathe depuis longtemps mais j'apprécie
beaucoup à la fois personnellement et
professionnellement et ça m'a plus
qu'émue sanaa a bouleversé j'ai préféré
parents de ma réaction publique je veux
envoyer un petit mot privé comme
certains d'entre nous ont choisi de le
faire
après sur le débat plus général dans la
mesure où c'est une décision intime de
révéler ou n'ont pas révélé sa maladie
c'est même une des décisions les plus
intimes qui soit c'est toujours la bonne
décision parce que c'est la décision de
la personne et personne n'est en droit
de juger que ces déplacés ou pas
déplacer ça n'appartient qu'à la
personne et je crois surtout que non
seulement ça donne de la force aux
autres mais sans d'autres ça libère pour
celui qui est malade de la force
de plus avoir à cacher de plus se poser
des questions est ce que je dois à
révéler ou pas pour consacrer toutes ses
forces à combattre la maladie
et il ya que ça qui compte donc je pense
que à tout point de vue d'un point de
vue général d'un point de vue
particulier de d'agathe c'est là c'était
la bonne décision elle a tout mon
soutien et j'ai compris tout notre
soutien et ont la main j'ai dit
qu'est-ce qu'il vous est celle qui est
la plus proche de gatineau parce que
vous la connaissez un peu plus que les
autres et et dans point de vue général
également alors deux points de vue
général je trouve que c'est bien de
jouer la transparence de devancer les
rumeurs briser le silence et ce n'est
pas sans risque c'est pour ça que je dis
que c'est courageux parce que de deux
choses l'une ou bien les gens vous en
parle tout le temps de bien les gens
vous fuit donc c'est pour ça que je dis
que c'est une décision courageuse de le
faire et encore brisé le silence c'est
fort tout simplement
et ça permet de dédramatiser ça permet
de ne pas se sentir seul c'est ce
message fort ce que les autres ont dit
justement parce qu'ils sont mal et pour
agathe personnellement voilà c'est la
définition même du courage il ya le
moment aussi pour le dire après
peut-être le déni elle va tout nous
raconter comment elle a pris la décision
vous avez gimme gimme mohamed en plus
vous êtes médecin
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous que là
je vous ai partagé je suis partagé parce
que bien sûr à la décision lui
appartient et donc si elle ressentait le
besoin l'envié la volonté libre à elle
de le faire et au qui sommes nous pour
dire elle devait elle ne devait pas je
pense que chacun est libre moi je pense
que je ne l'aurais pas fait je pense que
je garderai pour moi certaines choses
mais c'est pas trop le débat fait partie
désormais des patients que je vois tous
les jours de près des premiers symptômes
aux examens al'annonce de la maladie et
puis aux examens à l'hôpital l'odeur de
l'hôpital toutes ces petites choses qui
font que ben on se rend compte qu'on
peut s'appeler à gâteau pucci mohamed ou
tartempion on est tous égaux face à mme
la maladie et que c'est pas une fois
combien la boule blanche l'hôpital y a
pas de traitement de faveur
on est tous pareils et je pense que ça
donne un message d'espoir aux gens de se
dire bah c'est vrai qu'on voit les
photos d'un gâteau prou à elle est belle
on devait lui dire toute la journée qu
est ce que tu es belle
as-tu fait des vacances à tel endroit ta
vie à l'air génial mais d'un autre côté
il y avait sa maladie je peux comprendre
qu'on le dire mais peut-être que
j'échangerais votre vie contre la mienne
ce sens la maladie donc regarder ce
qu'est m'a réellement ma vie je brise ce
tabou je pense que ça a une vertu
parfois pédagogique j'ai souvenir des
noirs a malgré qui raconte son hôte de
mes trios ce qui fait découvrir aux gens
ce qu'est la maladie qui est souvent
méconnu quand on se rappelle du parcours
de pierre menez avec sa maladie du foie
ça permet de découvrir ce qu'est la
maladie du soda la question de la
transplantation le don d'organes et donc
je pense que ça peut faire évoluer les
mentalités et vine des liens avec la
maladie de parkinson une maladie et
c'est catherine laborde car ils
n'apportent pas évidemment avec la
malice d'excusés m'a accueilli leur
refus d'ailleurs exactement et qui font
que ces maladies qu'on entend souvent
mais finalement qu'on ne rencontre pas
toujours
je pense que c'est une bonne chose de
les donner demain je suis à des réglages
sont ce soir c'est en régie sahraoui
qu'est ce qui se voit là donc on s'est
juste des petits réglages merci ce que
je crois qu'à david guetta qui va faire
une émission merci oui et non et donc je
pense que ça peut libérer la parole
faire progresser les mentalités et tout
ca tout à son honneur de finalement de
se livrer à nous parce que c'est une
rave révélation quand je discute avec
les patients parfois ils n'osent même
pas le dire à leurs proches
alors le dire à tout le monde c'est
quelque chose d'important